like sorry i am more acceptant of my
mistakes i feel like when when people
remarry the reason why it doesn't work
is because they've not accepted the
mistakes they make you see for a
marriage to work
or for it to fail both parties have gone
wrong
whether you want to accept it or not
even whatever it is except for violence
obviously but
i believe both parties have gone wrong
like i i've accepted i know where i went
wrong in my marriage and i don't shaking
her head over there
oh okay and i i i know where i've gone
wrong he may have more fault than i did
right but i still know the bits i
attributed to in that marriage so i now
know that okay whatever i get into
i need to carry myself a certain way i
need to speak a certain way i need to so
long as i do my pit my bit my part right
he i can't guarantee he will do his part
right i can't predict what a guy will do
but also based on how i vet and choose
now
i find it hard to believe i'll get
divorced again because i'm not even in a
rush to get married i just want to do it
right this time
so you don't feel you'll get divorced
again i mean you never said you never
know you never never say never yet but i
get you okay so you feel like you've
learned from your mistakes
you were shaking your head yeah i don't
think um divorce is based on two people
doing something wrong i think there's
loads of marriages where
one person's just decided they just
don't want their marriage anymore and
it's not because of anything internal it
might really yeah it might actually be i
actually know one personal
that the woman just didn't want the
marriage anymore because she didn't love
him right i don't know no
i feel like okay but even but even if it
was because she didn't love him this was
the same man that you married yeah if he
hasn't
she probably married her second choice
yeah that's usually what happens is the
girl like they're getting closer to the
age where they need to have kids they
marry the first guy that'll take them
maybe and then and then they can't get
that x out of their head so they leave
to try to find something just so what
are the statistics again is it women
that leave marriages more right yeah
women women leave marriages 70 to 80
percent of the time if they're college
educated it's 90. yeah
okay
i personally believe that's down to the
fact that women have been sold a
hollywood version disney dream of what a
relationship is i do think social media
has confused people um i'm definitely an
example of that but obviously i've woken
up i feel like um
you look at social media and you see
these people are in love or when you see
people getting married but you don't
remember they've probably kissed so many
frogs they've gone through so many
heartbreaks they've gone through so many
things so now i don't that's why i said
i don't really go with statistics i just
go with what my reality is and what i've
learned and what i've deemed as wrong
and right okay i want to show you guys
something look at
the this is the divorce rate
this is oral contraceptive sorry this is
the divorce rate and this is oral
contraceptive use
[Music]
so
so basically the the so basically the
pill is what in my opinion broke
marriages because like look how similar
those are like literally as soon as the
pill was introduced people started
getting divorced yeah it's interesting
because
you think
definitely from my own experience like
my parents they stayed together because
they had a child
and i think that there's a lot of
families out there that stay together
because of children yeah and it can
cause it potentially does cause like
other potential deeper rooted issues and
longer down the line as well but i think
there are less and less people that are
willing to
yeah are willing to put themselves in a
marriage where they have to stay
together
for the sake of the child and then more
and more people are choosing to
look at what is a healthy environment
for a child now in a different whole way
so now that's probably now with this
whole now with maybe the freedom of that
contraception does give for women to
make choices
to to test out their options and to try
their options
it's like now
women have that choice to not stay in a
marriage that doesn't fulfill them
wouldn't it wouldn't it be better to
like work it out like figure out how to
get along with the guy right like
because because to me it's like what is
it isn't duty more important than
happiness so can i just say something
before i'm a mother i am a woman and if
i'm not happy as a woman i probably
wouldn't be happy as a mother yeah don't
isn't it about your kids happiness
though not yours no because my kids
like a human being and i'm a human being
just because i have had a child i take
responsibility of my child doesn't mean
that i do not deserve happiness right
but i'm saying i'm saying like like
to me once you have a kid it's not about
you anymore it's not about your
happiness like that should come suck
it's about my kids safety and my kids
environment well i don't i don't i don't
know your personality i'm saying in
general all mothers i think no matter
what you are a woman first you i was me
before i became a mother but i'm sad my
role just changed but i'm i'm saying
like wouldn't you say that it's not the
majority of women that are being abused
because i think that's what you were in
you said my safety no i said my child's
safety my child's environment right what
is important to me but shouldn't your
child's happiness make you happy
i think not necessarily because i'm
still a human being i'm still there were
things that made me happy prior to
having my happiness over
family duty like family duty what is
family duty like okay
happy environment okay my parents their
30th my parents 30th wedding anniversary
was two days ago let's go yeah yeah
shout out mom and dad but like there
there were times where they didn't like
each other and they weren't happy but
like judy was you know what i'm gonna
put the family before my personal
happiness
okay so i come i've come i've seen my
mum married and a single mom right and
i've also been married and become a
single mom
and when i was married and miserable and
depressed and all of that kind of stuff
i wasn't an attentive and good mother
but now that i am happy
right and i'm in a better space i'm so
attentive to my kids like i'm so i put
so much effort and time into my kids
it's unbelievable i know when
something's going wrong you see when the
mind is not at peace you look past and
dismiss it just pick up on things so so
question do you
do you think your kids would say the
same thing
like what would they think they would
prefer the parents apart yeah the the
kids may not prefer the parents apart
because they love both yeah but if they
were to look at the um us individually
and how especially if they were to look
at me individually and compare me to
then and now they'll prefer me do you
think that happiness is a choice their
happiness no do you think your happiness
you have some responsibility for how
happy you are yeah because i told you
based on the choices i've made
no i'm i'm talking about like like
to me like i could be in a shitty i'd
like i've been i've been in a
relationship where i wasn't happy before
but like
to me like your happiness is a choice
like i can choose in a day if i want to
look at things like with a good attitude
or i want to be unhappy so if you're
you're saying that if you're if your
preferences or things you like or how
you like to be treated in a relationship
and you're not being treated like that
you can choose to still be happy yeah
okay that's interesting did you choose
to stay happy in your relationship no i
never cared
about your happiness yeah what do you
mean well you have you weren't happy but
did you why didn't you choose to be
happy in that relationship
why didn't i chew well i was happy
that's what i'm saying you said you
weren't happy no i'm saying sorry i
thought you meant did you did you choose
to stay like are you still with him i
thought that was the question
no i'm what i'm saying is that i i was
still a happy person in that
relationship and like my family still
did you guys live together no see when
you're living together it's very
different imagine someone is
breaking your heart or hurting you and
you have to see them every day and play
house in front of your kids and you go
into your room and you cry and
everything and you're thinking i have to
make this work because of my children i
have to make and you just get inside
exactly
extreme of cases no but that's how it
that's how it leads though when when you
get to the point somewhere it starts
from somewhere
the example you're giving that's not
extreme that's not exactly that's not
even this is not even extreme this is
that word
so you're in a relationship